real sets practical effects you've been
here but you don't know this story
nothing's changed really I mean
everything's changed but nothing's
changed that's the way you want it to be
really
to sync the way the technology has
evolved and yet keeping one foot in the
pre-digital world
it couldn't be more exciting it's still
surreal we are here on day one
of Star Wars Episode seven yeah yeah how
incredible my whole life has led to this
moment JJ is trying to make sure these
movies have a physicality to them we
truly are out in a desert a real desert
Star Wars I'm just gonna bring this
character to life I was in the same room
as all these legends and with all these
new people who are pure born to be
legends themselves you know it's being
done with such love and such enthusiasm
from everybody and I think that you'll
be able to feel that coming off the
screen it means so much as so many
people you just know what's gonna be
like in the cinema
hey youtubers its charlie happy holidays
hopefully you guys have had a chance to
see Star Wars this is gonna be my first
Easter Egg video for all the cameos
there were a bunch of them mostly Game
of Thrones actors because they didn't
film a lot in London so if you haven't
seen it just careful for spoilers we
will be talking about stuff that does
happen in the movie so the biggest one
you've probably already heard about they
got obi-wan Kenobi himself Edwin
McGregor to come in James Arnold Taylor
was originally doing a small voice part
for when Ray touches the lightsaber
there's also Mark Hamill and Yoda voice
in there too but JJ Abrams was just like
hey let's try to get a one McGregor you
know let's try to get obi-wan from the
prequels in and he was really nice
wrote up on his motorcycle was in the
studio for a little while and then took
off JJ Abrams was like nicest guy ever
he was totally happy to come back for
those that don't know James Arnold
Taylor is the voice actor that does
obi-wan for the Clone Wars or did it for
the Clone Wars and for Star Wars rebels
but obi-wan Luke and Yoda can all be
heard whenever Rey touches the
lightsaber and he gives her the vision
that first time Game of Thrones actors
there are many the first one is Thomas
brodie-sangster who's a first-order
officer when Poe and Finn escape in the
TIE fighter there's an officer that
turns and lets the note like serve these
people are escaping that's Thomas
brodie-sangster he was Jojen Reed on
Game of Thrones
then we have Jessica Henrik who was
Nymeria sand from Game of Thrones
she played just Esther one of the
resistance fighters that went on that
final assaults on the Starkiller base
it's not really a cameo but Nina Gould
the casting director from Game of
Thrones was also the casting director
for Star Wars Episode 7 which gives you
an idea of why the Star Wars cast was so
awesome
Mark Stanley who was gren the
giant-slayer plays one of the clan
leaders that's in in that Knights of Ren
scene with kylo Ren here the actor that
played Syrio Forel was inside maz
kanata's bar he was one of the bar
patrons and everybody's still wondering
if he's alive Warwick Davis also another
bar patron during the Maz Kanata scenes
as well as Judah Friedlander from 30
rock you know two very different
physiques two other big abrams verse
people that showed up were greg grunberg
who's named snap Wexley that's the name
of his character he and Ken Lang were
both big resistance leaders they were
both part of lost and just in case you
never watched that TV show simon pegg
another really big cameo he played the
guy that kept giving ray food rations in
exchange for parts when han Solo runs
afoul of the bounty hunters that he
double-crossed Concha Club those people
are played
from the actors from the raid resistance
if you haven't seen it it's a really
awesome action film JJ Abrams said they
weren't meant to be like these really
big characters they had a really small
part it was kind of went off because
they got killed off mostly during that
scene but he said he really liked him
and wanted to work with him so he's like
you know please come in and do this you
know there it wasn't gonna be any heavy
martial arts or anything like that
another big resistance person Billie
lourd is Carrie Fisher's real-life
daughter she has like one brief line in
it but you see in the background of some
shots the woman that patches Chewie up
is as he's talking about how brave he
was she's a really big actor that did a
lot of work with Count Dooku Christopher
Lee is really hard to see him but JJ
Abrams put his dad in the movie in the
background of some of the resistance
scenes his name's Jerry Abrams
and then of course there's bb-8 the
voice was Bill Hader and Ben Schwartz he
may have heard me talk about that and
some of my other videos but Bill Hader
you ought you obviously know who that is
Ben Schwartz played John Rafi Oh during
Parks and Rec so just you know picture
him being really ridiculous speaking to
this little vocoder to make the sounds
and then probably like the most high
profile cameo that you may have picked
up on is Daniel Craig he played the
stormtrooper that raid did the Jedi mind
trick on now it's kind of hard to tell
his voice at first but if you go see the
movie again later when he walks around
to her it sounds a little bit more like
him he's speaking more in his natural
voice those are all the biggest
high-profile cameos let me know if you
spotted any that I didn't mention in the
video and let me know what was your
favorite cameo from the movie that you
actually recognized I think a lot of
people felt like they recognized Daniel
Craig at least a little bit just because
the last James Bond movie came out so
recently and his voice is so distinct
but because there's been a lot of
speculation about about questions that
the movie raises that have been answered
like who raised parents are Lawrence
Kasdan and JJ Abrams talked a little bit
about why they left so many questions
they said part of the reason is because
they wanted to like set the stage and
allow these other filmmakers that are
making the other films to answer him
however they wanted so like Ryan Johnson
for instance he's writing the story for
episodes 8 & 9 he's only directing
episode 8 the guy who did Jurassic world
is directing episode 9 so you know one
writer two different directors but a lot
of people are wondering if you know
maybe JJ Abrams Lawrence Kasdan who
wrote episode 7 didn't necessarily know
who they wanted Rey's parents to be like
that's just one example there's a lot of
questions that aren't answered in the
movie but that's just one of the biggest
ones like maybe they wanted to leave it
open for other directors to go
whichever the direction they wanted to
with it so if you still want to believe
she's a Kenobi that's still wide open if
you want to believe she's a Skywalker
that's still ok or if you want to
believe she's a solo or someone else the
craziest theory I've seen and I totally
don't believe this but I think it's a
lot of fun that she is secretly snoke's
daughter now the problem with that is is
that the evidence the people are using
for that is that in the the Star Wars
lookbook like the visual look book it
talks about Snoke at one time in his
life being very handsome but then
getting his features twisted by the dark
side and I think the idea is that he's
supposed to be as old as Maz Kanata like
really really old so I don't necessarily
have a lot of faith in that theory I
think it's more likely that she's Luke
Skywalker's daughter just you know based
on some of the visual clues but usually
my opinion changes just a little bit
every time I see the movie like okay you
know I can kind of see this Luke
Skywalker stuff the problem with making
theories about Ray's backstory is is
that you can't use a lot of EU and I
felt like early on that was what
influenced most of my theories is like
well this was a big arc and the EU they
kind of threw it out but they're kind of
doing some things that look like a very
you think like the idea that one of the
Skywalker's would name one of their
children Ben after Ben Kenobi in the EU
Luke Skywalker and Mara Jade named their
son Ben Skywalker so what I've learned -
like the last couple days is that it's
probably easier to theory craft if you
don't know anything about the EU just
kind of throw that to the side and use
the visual clues that the movie gives
you it's kind of the same thing with
comic book TV shows that don't
necessarily do comic book arcs but they
have characters from the comics so
what's gonna happen next is I'm just
gonna do like a general Q&A where all
I'll name the winner of the giveaway
that's actually still going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's
really simple just to iMacs gift
certificates so you can go see the movie
again or see for the first time if you
haven't seen it yet then I'll probably
start doing character videos I'm
probably gonna start with kylo Ren and
Rey just because they're the two most
interesting characters to come out of
the movie but why you guys wait for all
that stuff to go down you can click here
to learn all about the Knights of Ren
how they're a little bit different from
the Sith and in what they're doing with
this new trilogy and you can click here
for my non-spoilery review of the movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you